frente al parlamento danés estos sirios
no se han levantado de sus sillas desde
mediados de mayo protestan contra la
política migratoria del país que se ha
endurecido en los últimos años
la última medida es una ley que prevé la
apertura de centros de asilo en el
extranjero mustafa sigue sin poder
creerlo y se pregunta hasta dónde puede
llegar el gobierno danés
es increíble si es así cómo piensan
tengo miedo de todos aquí and they can't
go podrían actuar sin límites contra
nosotros
en la práctica un inmigrante que llega a
dinamarca sería enviado a un tercer país
donde se examinaría su solicitud pero
aunque se le concediera el estatuto de
refugiado no podría vivir en el reino de
dinamarca
esta joven estudiante danesa está
indignada por esta medida que hay de
media nacional para pagar uno después de
ver a dinamarca le encanta aparecer en
los medios de comunicación
internacionales por todos nuestros
aspectos positivos como por ejemplo el
hecho de que dinamarca haya sido
considerado como el país más feliz del
mundo pero las personas más felices del
mundo están destruyendo la vida de las
personas que más han sido maltratadas en
el mundo
dinamarca es también el único país de
europa que considera segura la región de
damasco en siria por ellos usan antigua
residente de la capital siria recibió
hace dos meses una carta en la que se le
comunicaba que no se le había renovado
el permiso de residencia
mis hijos y yo vinimos aquí para
construir un futuro pero después de dar
lo mejor de nosotros aquí esta carta lo
destruyó todo
es de damasco es una abuela que tiene
todos estos niños aquí ellos quieren que
regrese a siria
para esta mujer es un doble golpe ya que
el sistema de asilo europeo no le
permite solicitarlo en otro país de la
unión europea
en europa está prohibido estar en
cualquier país europeo nadie me da una
solución a dónde voy porque debo ir a la
corte no soy una delincuente
[Música]
esta adolescente también está muy
inquieta tenía apenas 8 años cuando huyó
de damasco
samán colín maderenses me acuerdo del
día en que alguien llame a mi papá y le
dijo que alguien venía que estaba
matando gente recuerdo que mi papá me
sacó de la casa teníamos mucho miedo yo
era pequeña pero aún no recuerdo porque
fue horrible me afectó profundamente
todavía está en mi memoria nuestras
peticiones para entrevistar a las
autoridades danesas fueron rechazadas
para justificar esta política migratoria
el ministerio de inmigración se apoya en
este comunicado
el actual sistema de asilo es un fracaso
es ineficiente e injusto niños mujeres y
hombres se están ahogando en el
mediterráneo' el gobierno danés propone
un nuevo sistema de asilo justo y humano
para beneficio de los países de destino
tránsito y origen hasta ahora ningún
tercer país ha aceptado tener centros de
asilo aunque este proyecto siga siendo
hipotético las ong están preocupadas
si por ejemplo el gobierno de australia
creó centros de asilo fuera del
territorio australiano en la isla de
naurú y en otras islas donde se
produjeron numerosas violaciones de los
derechos humanos de los refugiados y
solicitantes de asilo
por no hablar de la falta de solidaridad
con otros países de la unión europea una
política sorprendente viniendo de un
gobierno socialdemócrata
es un nuevo y muy fuerte indicador de
este gobierno socialdemócrata es el
distanciamiento de la unión europea los
anteriores líderes socialdemócratas
destacaron la importancia de la
cooperación con otros gobiernos europeos
y la integración de dinamarca en la
unión europea pero este gobierno tiene
una posición mucho más euroescéptica y
además la situación está siendo seguida
de cerca en bruselas pero la unión
europea tiene poco poder para llamar a
dinamarca al orden
dinamarca es un caso especial porque se
retiró de la servo en materia de asilo e
inmigración lo que significa que no
están obligados a seguir todo el observó
que tenemos en estos ámbitos pero por
supuesto el tratado y la carta de los
derechos fundamentales deben seguir
siendo respetados
mientras tanto los refugiados sirios de
la región de damasco viven con el temor
de perder sus permisos de residencia en
dinamarca
nos encontramos con susan fuera de la
corte vino a apoyar a una amiga que tras
estos muros espera el juicio que
decidirá su futuro en copenhague
sé que tiene miedo
hemos hablado estos últimos días es muy
difícil ir a la corte como delincuentes
pero más de cuatro horas después llega
el alivio
raya podrá permanecer en dinamarca otros
dos años
y es lo mismo